DISASTROUS AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL.
BRIAN HILLSBURG, THE FORMER CIA
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER SPY X.COM
ANALYST AND THE DIRECTOR OF
CORPORATE SECURITY AT A GLOBAL
BIOTECH COMPANY.
SO THIS IS A PRETTY BRAVE
MISSION THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
PULLED OFF, WAS IT WORTH IT.
>> HI, JESSE, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME ON THE SHOW.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS DONE
NORMALLY WITH OUR LIAISON
PARTNERS AND COUNTRIES THAT
SUPPORT AND A LOT OF THE
TRAINING THAT IS PROVIDED IS
REALLY SOME OF THE BEST TRAINING
IN THE WORLD.
AND REALLY SOME OF THE REPORT
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER 2014 ABOUT CIA'S
PARAMILITARY OFFICERS ENTERING
UKRAINE AND HELPING THEM TRAIN
AND PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT I ANY
THAT'S NECESSARY AND SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS REGULARLY AROUND
THE WORLD AND I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT THIS REPORT HAS COME OUT
AND THAT THEY WERE DOING
SOMETHING BEING PRO-ELMIVE AND
PROACTIVE AND PREVENTATIVE.
REALLY AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
SOURCES, PROTECTING OUR METHODS
AND A LOT OF TRAINING THAT WE DO
DO IS CLANDESTINED.
IT'S SECRET, AND THAT'S WHY WE
REALLY HAVEN'T KNOWN WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE BEFORE THE LAST
FEW WEEKS.
>> Jesse: HOW BIG OF A
DIFFERENCE WAS THE CIA
PARAMILITARY TRAINING AND DO YOU
THINK IT HAS MORE TO DO WITH
THAT TRAINING OR MORE TO DO WITH
FEROCIOUS AND PATRIOTIC SPIRIT
OF THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE?
>> I DEFINITELY THINK THAT THE
PATRIOTISM AND FEROCIOUS SPIRIT
OF THE UKRAINIANS THAT'S REALLY
FROM WHAT I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TELL FIRST AND FOREMOST WHAT
THEY HAVE TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
ALSO, HAVING BEEN THROUGH A LOT
OF CIA TRAINING, WHETHER AT THE
FARM OR OTHER LOCATIONS, IT
REALLY IS THE WAY THAT THEY
TRAIN PEOPLE THEY WANT TO MAKE
THE TRAINING SO DIFFICULT, SO
STRESSFUL AND SO STRENUOUS THAT
ANYTHING THAT YOU SEE OR DO OR
EXPERIENCE IN THE REAL WORLD
WILL HOPEFULLY BE EASY.
NOW, IT'S A DIFFERENT MATTER, OF
COURSE, IN A WAR ZONE
ENVIRONMENT BUT I CAN ATTEST
AFTER BEING IN THE AGENCY FOR 13
YEARS, NOTHING I REALLY DID IN
THE REAL WORLD WAS AS DIFFICULT
AS WHAT I WAS PUT THROUGH IN
TRAINING.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD WAY TO
TRAIN PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU THINK I
WOULD DO AT THE FARM, RYAN?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT JUST DEPENDS.
IT'S ALL MENTAL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IT'S A LOT
OF PHYSICAL TRAINING AND THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF THAT ASPECT.
BUT IT REALLY IS A MENTAL
EDUCATION AND YOU NEVER KNOW.
YOU HAVE TO LIVE AND WORK IN THE
GRAY.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE AUTO BLACK AND
WHITE MENTALITY, BLACK AND WHITE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE WORLD
OFTENTIMES STRUGGLE TO GET
THROUGH THE FARM.
BUT IF YOU CAN DEAL WITH
AMBIGUITY.
IF YOU LIVE AND WORK IN THE GRAY
IN TERMS OF YOUR MINDSET AND
YOUR OUTLOOK OF THE WORLD.
YOU ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND
YOU WILL BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.